yeah hello and welcome to this video I'm
going to play a bit of bullet chess
let's do it not my forte but yeah you
can try this is actually a long one
right anyway let's go for it it's a
daily arena problem and no not so much
explanation here but more action so if
we get a French defense by a
transposition I shouldn't play 96 they
might play Bishop g5 okay so he gave me
the should pay oh that's nice
lack in development but other than that
I'm a fine
gives me a good pawn on d4 nice so what
is he going to do with you before New
Orleans I'm trying to prevent it at
least for the moment didn't work okay
but I'm ahead of the clock I maybe I
could have preserved here but yeah
buzzer King and bullet chess is always
tricky for me and sometimes I just don't
have the speed so for me it's probably
not bad to just play play the games and
see that I win most of them
looks like a good good one here going to
promote only one yeah so I'm a bit bit
behind of course I think it's like eight
or nine minutes late ninety six come on
come on behalf okay knight c6 that's a
somewhat okay pre move I should take me
for but okay it's what it is the lane
cast along an auditor do forms come on
go for g5 that's definitely dangerous
not sure how good it is but it is
dangerous
oh yeah push up on v6 was quite strong
okay so I'm catching up yeah maybe I
should have preserved to one or two of
those but I know that I'm going to lose
schemes on time thirty seconds is really
a bit much from him oops
take that maybe he was speculating on
the Cree move hello how my opponents
doing ed looks like he committed suicide
and the full/queen up I mean a
full/queen so cutely he's not resigning
this which would be nice I need 10 8
games
okay so 23rd place okay yeah I should
get closer to God sure but I think
that's any of anybody's super strong
competing I mean I am not good enough to
compete with the best bit of players but
against the kind of normal people I
usually do quite okay not so nice
yeah good good play here by black my
bishop on b2 is not exactly strong there
are some end games that would be okay
but my bishop comes tech b6 and that
would be nice night against Bishop is
also not so bad okay
it's an interesting way to do it I can
put the night loops
I'm to c4 I didn't really see that my
time was so low position wins now I have
to say Auto Queen Auto Queen Auto Queen
where is it
Auto Queen game behavior
- Queen always yes yeah I'm getting
paired that was awful completely
outplayed the guy when I was really slow
I wasn't really sure what happened them
I was really so so I was Chris snow
right
it takes on g3 and IQ didn't happen
not easy
I should be okay here but it's not not
easy to play and this bishop here is a
bit of a pain
I don't know people with such a crap
rating and they play really strong are
all of a sudden here playing very slowly
as well
I came huh not really not really kind of
into the flow of the bullet time control
six well you can try and they play so
quickly it can be any sort of wacky
previous
Wow it's the queen really let's get to
the top 20 M we have got 40 minutes left
so it should be possible Oh
f5 really
I don't think the King on the edge is
something that black is especially happy
with okay so you give me give me other
thing okay so please mikesh liquor won't
come out right really high rating
no porn up for not much actually
yeah this is of course objectively
absolutely not working but this is a
little tricky here mm-hmm it doesn't
threaten anything sure can you even go
to age three still not threatening
anything I just have six seconds it's
the problem
I'm just freaking slow Liam I don't know
why am I so slow I've played a bit of
bullets over the last couple of weeks
just to kill time a little bit but I'm
really slow
I mean chess wise the games are very
very one-sided but I'm just not quick
enough
you
at least I'm not losing this on time
it looks very probable okay I'm creeping
slowly I mean I should just like win the
completely winning games is nothing 94
was even stronger not quite sure what my
opponent is after him
we sometimes can play this nonsense if
you are clearly better player but if you
are clearly the worst player it usually
doesn't work
I actually blundered stuff there but he
didn't didn't react okay so
I'm on 14 seconds this is what I don't
get where do I lose all the time
am I really so slow obviously I am I
mean
don't quite understand why okay you
deserve that one it's too weird why I'm
so slow somehow not really in the bullet
bullet frame
okay wow that's not good
it seems like I'm playing against
somebody like no stuff and when I knew I
said I already made a mistake with the
move order I think maybe nothing serious
but something that is quite quite a
problem with the to this time controller
you know it's so easy to play for black
yeah I think I'm somehow getting killed
probably yes and he sees this stuff
immediately with the made on b2 and crap
and then you lose against the 1800 Jim
fantastic great no I know playing the
open Sicilian it's tricky anyway for me
and the dragon and his term control
especially problematic
making a single bad move him then come
on come on and then somehow it cannot
move on what create great self what a
disaster you okay
okay let's focus I really don't want to
finish 20 years when I'm the best player
in the tournament like usually at least
I would be the best player so let's see
and I just have to play with them and
then what probably the dragon I mean I
even would have won that on time if
somehow they wouldn't have this mouse
glitch it is it's so close
that's a complete complete disaster from
black
made next I can pretty move that okay
there's three points back and I cannot
get this serious going I just lose every
other game just 30 minutes
you know just wins a piece queen bee 694
as the Queen has to sacrifice on before
no many moves are good great meat
so I'm just a piece up now double attack
f7 and c6 meet under mid threatened
Bishop c5 is again made threats made
next okay on the first page but okay
this is - hey this is also one of the
games I think Street fire we're lost
from a winning position Jamison very
quickly playin by like oh that's
actually the first place or one of the
first places
see
and the a part is quick
know what the heck
okay now that was stupid
I should've really registered that this
is a good player we played this rubbish
opening and you automatically think okay
then some pet so you can do anything
against but okay obviously not
yeah I've got some very good
compensation here didn't see that it's
still pretty difficult for black his
dark squares are just completely
terrible
queen of age I think he cannot stop it
just made the heck is garbage sim mmm
now and I really I didn't register that
this was was a strong bullet player when
he played that weird opening with Bishop
e2 and e3 and everything
he's good it's misplaced is there a
little bit but it's so not so easy
no it doesn't doesn't really the
exchange is not a huge issue him the
only question is how much better black
is him
cannot keep this unfortunately
yeah pretty clearly winning them yeah
tough yeah so after all there are some
good for good players and the first on
the first page oh my god whatever black
does not seem to like developing
you know I can do this this is also
quite good
I have to watch out for the time that's
the main problem here that could be a
factor you know but 17 seconds is enough
eight plates yeah maybe maybe third
maybe
what happens if he doesn't play the move
no he does play them yeah black is very
okay yeah played us a little bit on a
little bit some unambitious it's a very
normal position for bullet game
oops III did not have on the radio
nah yeah this is the things I mean okay
anyway you can goes to one movies
as six know this one
yeah come on come on can just take the
friggin book ah yes
and I just don't have the street smarts
yeah if I'm not really in full bullet
mode and do so many games that are just
well you should do with simply okay
I'm gonna take that that was stupid I
was again kind of again thinking about
relax pretty terrible opening a whites
terrible opening and then i blundered
the default prom
they might screw it up somehow yeah I
know wind the Queen okay
well its first second place okay
Jim yeah I'm just fine you absolutely
fine get the Queen's traded and have the
better position I think yeah maybe it's
equal
maybe equal
it's interesting interesting
yeah I make time freakin time yeah
Bishop a stream he tricked me and from
that absolutely nothing position okay
yeah hi tactics and all small move
tactics maybe I should have played this
a bit simpler I just take on the four
earlier where was there was much simpler
yeah garvik's is just killing everything
here that's amazing
so pretty much you win out of the
opening well you still have to win it I
can plain I could have played 97 earlier
okay yeah little guy was actually ahead
of me I never get four points is the
problem
they're always loose games like before I
can get some sort of winning streak in I
can only not in reCAPTCHA I wasn't
stupid idea I thought I get to pieces
and in a somewhat cool position but I
don't I get the Queen back maybe yeah I
get the Queen back many material changes
in this position in this game
okay Oh gob exactly just one might like
12 points ahead yeah something went
wrong here don't like this it's a case
playing some strange moves as well
what
what's the tickler the bishop
discover the second Ranga no chicks
please
fifth place and maybe third yeah if
everything works works out but kuku law
was such a cool name like a tick 95
maybe it is still okay because the night
on these two is just so utterly
misplaced probably this is the qiam
okay
not a heavy move but if I cannot go just
blend at this
my it's still tough for white okay when
I have drawn oh I was funny should have
traded okay okay come on for the place
just playing this for simplest
simplicity's sake so that's simpler to
play than the complex queen's gambit
yeah sure chica I have six first
to resign yes so at least third for the
moment topics really killed the
competition area why not two more games
I have got garvik's okay your own idea
three I'm just playing my flow full
openings now
mmm very strong flame
now and we look at Medicaid the
deposition is a draw of course before
word now it's got 30 seconds
yeah not I did not play it well okay
talk about wacky game I'm winning the
exchange here and it's a it's a decent
enough position
and to 100 kala cats - yeah I don't get
the food for points yeah
the French my transposition was a fairly
good version but I probably still get
checkmated as I usually do this is
mostly to prevent a fire okay okay maybe
I should cover this
I've got to check let's take this pawn
yeah so fifth at the end yeah yeah yeah
very good job here by garvik's yeah it
was clearly the best in the tournament I
guess and I also lost two games pretty
much clear Liam yes there wasn't really
any any big hope in those games okay
that was the daily bullet arena my
Arabic daily one okay it was a bit long
in one hour but it was just I was
thinking okay let's go for a bullet a
bullet event and that was the one that
was around ok guys hope you enjoyed it
bullet is a bit of fun once in a while
but don't overdo it thanks for watching
bye bye